The Tuileries is the only
commission we ever fulfilled.
In fact, we've been offered,
not so much recently
but in the early days we were always
asked if we do something for
a particular project or something.
We always said,
"We don't want to go to the studio
with some other information
in our head.
We want to go
empty headed, blank."
“Zonked,” we say.
With the eyes closed...
and closing the ears to be–
nothing and then we can...
fall into some truth
of some kind, hopefully.
We never wanted to...
We never wanted
to go up to the studio
with the idea that
we have to satisfy somebody.
But we did it for Art & Project
as they were some of the first
people to be kindly to us.
We were introduced to Art & Project
by the late artist Ger van Elk
who wanted us
to join his Dutch gallery.
He felt it would be good
for him as well and good for us.
And we became very fond
of Ger and Adriaan, I recalled.
Adriaan died quite recently
and they wanted something
that they would keep for themselves
and we said
we would do The Tuileries.
And it's very interesting
because then...
at that time, we used
to have a lot of shows in Paris.
with Ileana Sonnabend
and the friends of...
what do you call...
We had a group of young people
taking us around
and we ended up in the Tuileries.
And at that time, the Tuileries
was a kind of sex playground.
Sex playground hiding
in the bushes or something.
So it became a new way
of dealing with nature that it could
have a bit of sexual element.
The trees are not only trees,
it could be something
behind the trees.
So to make up...
The images in The Tuileries
are not of the Tuileries.
We could've gone
to Paris and done that
but we didn't need to do that.
It just had to be the suggestion
of the sexuality
combined with nature.
We were quite excited by that.
And the chairs are based on,
what do you call?
In 1970, we had two green chairs
in the ground floor
of number 12 Fournier Street.
We only had the ground floor.
It had two rooms.
It had the kitchen and one room.
And, for ten years
all the art was done there,
in the kitchen,
it was extraordinary.
And only two chairs.
All of the famous pieces,
like the Red Mornings,
or Cherry Blossom,
all were done in the kitchen.
And we had these two green chairs
and we asked John
if he could copy
the two green chairs.
And then we put this jungle,
what do you call?
-The Tuileries?
-On top of it.
It was very exciting. There were
a pair of, I suppose they were...
some prototypes of chairs
that never actually got produced.
And we liked them, because
they were similar but different.
Whenever we had a visitor
we always used to say,
"It's a male and female pair
of chairs. Which is which?"
And half the world says, that's
the man, and the other half says...
We realized that even the furniture
had that very strong sexual element.
We were fascinated by that.
Yeah, sexual...
To bring in
sexuality into the art...
was quite unusual
as well at that time.
It was one of the many taboos.
Color was taboo.
Sentiment was taboo.
-Sexuality was taboo.
-Being unhappy was taboo.
-And sexuality was totally...
-Sexuality was totally taboo.
Using your hands was taboo.
You talk about
being in a generation
that was largely
conceptual and minimal
in post-studio, and you were
very much an outpost-studio.
Yeah, that's true.
And we were very lucky that we were
poor enough not to have a studio.
It didn't hurt us at all.
It was very good because it became
abstract in some global way.
We didn't have a studio to go
back into it and start stretching.
We were able...
We only had to...
promoting our feelings
through other ways of thinking
and that's why we started
to become more involved
in the power of the negative.
We saw that through that power
we could make our
pictures or sculptures
much more powerful,
much more direct,
and much more real.
We felt that everything
that has to do with artistic hand,
the artistic hand,
it tried to take away all of that...
That you end up
in front of powerful imagery.
That's why we gave up
charcoal-on-paper sculptures
because we became...
-Disillusioned.
-We became very disillusioned with...
the reality that people came
to the charcoal-on-paper sculptures
and admired
their form and their texture.
And almost the sound
they made, their crinkliness.
And the edges, they liked
the edges and we thought,
"How awful.
They're not listening to us.
We're not reaching,
speaking to them."
We are not able
to get our message across
so let's try something different,
we tried different ways.
Like even videos,
we tried videos.
The first video sculpture
that we saw
that's quite a good way
of doing it
and we only did three because at that
time we didn't want to make our films
because we did it
with Gerry Schum,
from Gallery Schum in Dusseldorf
at that time: 1971, '72, '73.
But after that, in 1980,
we did write
an extraordinary script
of the world of
Gilbert & George.
And that we did storyboard
and every shot was designed by us
and we think that it's still
one of the best things we ever did.